cancer actually affect all the people
but not equally so it can affect rich or
poor
white or black and anyone in any
geographical location
certain groups of people whether because
of their gender race
socioeconomic status or where they live
see
worse outcomes from cancer this includes
cases and deaths but also screening and
quality of life after treatment these
differences
known as cancer health disparities are
part of professor sulma mohammed's
research
into the prevention of cervical and
breast cancer in sub-saharan africa
if we look at breast cancer in
in women of african descent we will see
that
the incident is the same as the incident
in white women
but they are 40 percent more to die
from the breast cancer when they're
compared to white women
in the united states cervical cancer is
very uncommon
but cervical cancer is the second most
common cancer
in sub-saharan african women and the
most uh
cancer that women die from the reasons
for cancer disparities are complex
and can include access to health care
behavioral factors like smoking
as well as education and wealth
selma has worked in sudan where she has
tried to understand the clinical and
cultural factors that contribute to
health disparities in breast and
cervical cancer
we found that women in the rural area
they present with late stage disease
more than women in urban areas so that
is given the idea
if we can do something about that so we
know that
screening usually done with mammography
but mammography is not available in
students there is one
mammography and it costs 200
to get a screening 200
is it is is actually a whole month
salary
of a physician forget about the you know
the other people
so that's a lot of money so we could not
do mammography
so we said we want to raise awareness
and we want to come with a program
that's more culturally appropriate
to to screen for cancer and so because
these women
in these villages they are not educated
they don't know much about cancer so and
if a woman has
like a lump on her breast she will think
this is
you know something is going to go away
you know she's not going to spend the
whole day
you know to travel from one place to
another so she can just to see what it
is
and also like we have a culture of you
know people are
fatally fatalist and they say you know
this the mostly muslim people and they
say
you know if allah want me to die you
know i will die i'm not gonna go through
the trouble of doing it right now
so this is all you know contributing to
these women not to go and seek
help so we found that our our approach
using this local volunteer from the
village with the same culture
is very successful to having the women
come out and look for for treatment
another project in my laboratory is to
develop a point of care test
for the early detection of cervical
cancer we know that cervical cancer
screening is very important in low
income countries
so if we can have a test that can be
immediately
read and within you know the first visit
and treat immediately that is very
important because
we don't wanna take the sample until the
women come back again most of them they
don't come back
so we need to do a test that immediately
and also this test
it can be done at home the same as
pregnancy test
but as well as all these factors perhaps
the least understood of all
is the role of biology in creating
cancer health disparities
we still don't know a lot about it
and hopefully that is one of the
milestones that
we're looking for for the future with
advances in genomic
and proteomic and bioinformatic
techniques
we were able to understand there is
differences in genetic predeposition
in cancer and also
identifies some molecular subtype
um between this population that in
breast cancer breast cancer now is
divided into four subtypes
and we found that the tribute negatives
of by bush is more aggressive
disease is more prevalent in women of
african descent
the major milestone i think that we have
achieved
in cancer disparity is that the
acknowledgement there is constant
disability exists
and there is focus now to understand it
and try
to work and to see how we can
help eliminate this cancer disparity for
future milestones
we wanted to invest in young scientists
to invest in clinical trials and build
cancer research
and very important is expanding the
diversity and biological region
that we use in cancer research that
could broaden our
understanding of cancer you